the Irish border was at the heart of 30
years of violence
now the checkpoints and fortified
British army bases have gone the
troubles have ended and people and goods
flow across the border but brexit
threatens this progress why the open
border between Northern Ireland and the
Republic of Ireland allows people to
identify as British or Irish or both but
during a 30-year conflict known as the
troubles the British Army fortified and
closed the border to stop terrorist
groups like the IRA moving between the
two countries but communities were
separated sectarian violence between
Catholic and Protestants continued and
the checkpoints and army bases became a
symbol for those opposed to British rule
the checkpoints were dismantled after
the Good Friday Agreement was signed the
open border allows people and goods to
move freely across the island of Ireland
but unless a deal is struck bricks it
could lead to the return of a hard
border as immigration and customs checks
would need to take place between the two
countries that's because after brexit
the United Kingdom will be out of the
European Union the EU will have a new
external border where Northern Ireland
meets the Republic of Ireland the border
is 310 miles long weaving through
countryside lakes rivers and farmland
there are 208 crossings where every
month over 170,000 lorries and 200,000
vans travel between the two countries
every day around 30,000 people cross the
border to get to work so someone needs
to figure out how to keep things moving
this is where the backstop comes in
Baxter Baxter backstop backstop the back
the backstop is simply a back-up plan
for politicians British Irish any you
figure out what to do next
if the EU and UK can't reach a new
training arrangement the UK as a whole
remains in the customs union with the EU
while Northern Ireland would follow
further EU rules and regulations to keep
the Irish border frictionless but some
argue this is risky because it would
effectively trap a UK and a customs
union with the EU which wasn't the goal
of people who voted to leave an
alternative arrangement proposed
originally by the EU is a backstop
applying to Northern Ireland only to
keep the border open and trade flowing
that would mean avoiding controls and
checks on the island of Ireland because
the customs border would be here but
there is opposition to this idea - as
Northern Ireland would be treated
differently to the rest of the UK which
could be free to strike trade bill